[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
preparations are underway for the derek
chauvin trial our exclusive interview
with the organization
funding his defense we feel strong in
the case
plus the national organization of black
law enforcement executives
calling for reform and new legislation
you have to acknowledge a problem
the accused killer of rapper nibsy
hussell is asking for a bail reduction
is eric holder a danger to the community
and the billion dollars in settlement
one university will pay out to sex
assault victims of a former campus
gynecologist
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin and angenette levy we begin with
team coverage of the derek chauvin trial
and jeanette leads us off with an
exclusive interview with the man who has
the organization that's paying for
showman's defense
brian the minnesota police and peace
officers association
lobbies for pro-law enforcement
legislation in the state
and the group also has a legal defense
fund for its members
i spoke with the executive director
about a number of issues
including minnesota's attorney general
and what he believes are the strengths
in chauvin's case
this is such a very important case and
the world is watching
brian peters has led the mppoa since
2019.
nothing could have prepared peters for
what happened on may 25th
2020 when a video of george floyd's
arrest recorded by a teenage girl
went viral you asked me earlier what i
thought of the video
when i first saw it it was hard it was
hard to watch
but peter says his opinion on that video
started to change
after he watched the police body camera
video that showed the beginning of the
encounter with george floyd
evidence wasn't released right away and
when i started looking at the evidence
also being able to watch all of the body
camera video
things started to change and being
experienced in law enforcement
not everything is what it what it seems
to be just from one aspect of the video
peters won't comment on the officer's
actions that day
but he believes the body camera video
the medical examiner's report
and the officer's training all helped
their cases
he questions why attorney general keith
ellison didn't want the body camera
released in the beginning
i sat on a working group called
deadly how to how to reduce deadly force
encounters
and this was led by our our attorney
general and our commissioner of public
safety we met for nine months and this
is pre george floyd
our attorney general spoke of needing
transparency
in these cases meaning release of body
camera video
as soon as possible making sure that
these investigations don't take
years you know to go from investigation
to conclusion at court
peters also questions why ellison wanted
to keep cameras out of the courtroom
we want to make sure that the facts are
the facts and people can make up their
own decision
themselves instead of relying on whether
it's a media report or a statement from
the attorney general people are going to
be able to see the facts firsthand
the stakes couldn't be higher and the
meaning of justice couldn't be more
different for the floyd family
and derek chauvin only a murder
conviction will mean justice for the
floyds
for derek chauvin it's an acquittal
lawyer eric nelson is defending chauvin
he's one of 12 lawyers the mppoa has
vetted to defend
officers three other lawyers are
defending thomas lane
alexander king and two tao even though
each attorney representing the
individual
has different um parts within the case
it does all come together that of course
all four attorneys
were working very hard with each other
we feel strong in the case
i think if the attorney general's office
felt the same
i don't understand why they need as many
attorneys on this case as
as they do so do you think that there is
any room for reform within the
minneapolis police department
absolutely i think there's there's room
for reform
um across the united states but as i
stated earlier there's also
a lot of room for reform at our
legislative
bodies whether it's at the state or
federal level
really working on some of these decade
long problems that nobody seems to be
able to fix
and peter said those problems include
drug abuse and
equities in education and poverty he
didn't want to comment on specific
aspects of the case right now
because of judge cahill's warnings and
you saw how upset he got
over the last week or so with the city
of minneapolis and the comments city
officials have been making there
brian thanks angeannette many in law
enforcement disagree with chovin's
actions that day
terry austin has more on the head of a
national organization who is looking to
see accountability
brian i spoke with linda williams the
president of the national organization
of black
law enforcement executives she says the
incident inspired her organization
to call for legislation mandating
intervention by
officers when they see another officer
using excessive force
in 30 years of being a special agent
with the united states secret service
i and i was very good never put anybody
on the ground
never laid on anybody's neck even when
there was an arrest that was affected
it was done properly in humane because
law enforcement is that entity in
society
that has been given that ultimate that
ultimate authority
to use death as you know as a final uh
you know resolution
it does not come to that we have to be
accountable for the training
and those people that lack or do not do
that they have to be held accountable
and i know it's simple but it's just a
mom and just
the hero man cry for his mother but the
fact is you had him under control so why
are you still at that point utilizing
excessive force we have to tarry
everybody
have to reimagine law enforcement we
have the public safety
is more than a villain in a badge it's
us
taking pride and you know reinvesting
into our communities
and that's a holistic approach
thanks harry let's bring in criminal
defense attorney bernard violina on this
as well
granada what did you make of the
comments there in terry's interview
where you have us i mean how do you get
better experience in special force of
the united states
of america in talking about when forced
sugar shouldn't be used and when it's
excessive
this conversation is a conversation that
we have been having for years
we have been having this same
conversation for over since
20 30 years and it still has remained
the same
change has only come little by little at
some
point come on you're going to keep on
having situations
like that of george floyd who died these
are situations that we hear
all around the country at some point
this has to stop
how do we get there is it by suing
people and getting money by the city
is it by taking away qualified immunity
is it by the criminal cases
something has to give agree terry
what did you make of brian peters
measures response on the case of
derek chovin well you know peters is
probably being very careful for a couple
of reasons first
he knows that the world is watching and
he probably wants to make sure that he's
being fair
and that he's being impartial even
though obviously he has one point of
view
and second he knows judge cahill has
already cautioned
all the parties to limit their comments
and even as it applies to the press not
just to the parties
so i think he's being very careful and
he's being
neutral if he can be no and jeanette
brian
peters seems to be pretty critical of
the attorney general keith ellison
i think there's no love lost between the
two of them
yeah i mean it kind of sounds like that
but in really having we had a really
long conversation brian about
35 or 40 minutes and he said he simply
just has a lot of questions for the
attorney general
as you heard him say they worked on that
panel together to reduce
use of force incidents they had worked
on some possible reforms that they
recommended to the state
legislature up there in minnesota and
then the floyd case happened and
everything kind of fell apart
so he said even today he would still sit
down and talk with the attorney general
he just has a lot of questions regarding
his handling of this particular case of
course the concept of reform will be
hanging over this trial as it begins uh
in the coming days still ahead on law
and crime daily the suspect accused of
killing
grammy winner rapper nipsey hussell
wants out of jail but first
the shocking evidence the jury in the
george floyd case is expected to hear
did derek shobin order a woman to be
hogtied who wasn't resisting arrest
[Music]
welcome back opening statements in the
derrick shogun murder trial are
scheduled to start on monday
law and crimes kim johnson is in
minneapolis and explains what evidence
is expected to come in
brian when the trial gets underway next
week the jury
will be allowed to hear about derrick
shovin's
previous police action in one previous
arrest chauvin received a life-saving
award for placing a handcuffed man
on his side an action which hospital
staff later told him
saved the man's life this week judge
peter cahill ruled that the incident was
important because it showed chauvin's
knowledge reasonable force in a similar
incident to what george floyd
experienced in may 2020.
the jury will also hear about another
arrest in 2017 when shobin placed a
woman
in a hog tie even though she was not
resisting
arrest as evidence is presented in court
next week family and friends of george
floyd are hoping
for a guilty verdict i hope that
the police officer do some jail time
because um when you look at the video
everybody telling them he can't breathe
he you know he's saying he need help the
officer continued to put his knee in his
neck
uh i feel the time
he told him he was claustrophobia and he
couldn't breathe
they should have set him on the curb
called for paramedics
now george floyd's friend tells me that
uh he thinks the racial makeup of the
jury which includes six people of color
is
fair and he says that he hopes justice
is served brian
thanks kim here to break down the
judge's ruling and the makeup of the
jury is criminal defense attorney
bernardo violona
and terry austin terry do you agree with
floyd's friend does the racial makeup of
the jury appear
fair to you i do agree i think that
it's not only racially diverse but you
have nine women six men
and the fact that you do have six of the
15 jurors
who are from diverse backgrounds i also
think it's important that they have
different professions so you have
someone who is an auditor you have
someone who
is a chemist you have a single mom those
types of perspectives will be
important when they're doing
deliberations you're going to want to
hear
everyone's opinion so i think the
diversity is
excellent and i think they did a good
job frankly of picking
people who will at least try to be fair
bernardo what do you make of the judge's
ruling to include
prior acts by chauvin so i'm not
surprised at the judge's ruling remember
that the prosecution in this case
actually was seeking to put an
eight of chauvin's prior bad acts into
evidence
and what the judge decided which was a
fair decision that only two of those
acts are going to be allowed in front of
the jury
because those two acts go to knowledge
and intent
specifically the act where a man was
tasered
and he was rolled to his side because
when he was in the hospital
the people at the hospital had stated
had he still been
facing the ground for any much longer
that he would have died so
that goes to show you knowledge on the
part of shoving he was aware
that having floyd down face down with
his knee on his neck
could cause death i mean it's called a
recovery position for a reason
of course if this test when it comes in
it's going to be very damaging for the
defense
be sure to tune in to the law and crime
network for gavel to gavel coverage of
the derek chovin
murder trial in the death of george
floyd for more on what's going on at the
law and crime network let's hand it over
to jesse weber
host of the show prime crime
yeah hey there brian tonight we discuss
sean great this is the serial killer who
lured women in
and then murdered them we're going to
start with the harrowing 9-1-1 call of a
woman who was able to escape
and then dive into the twisted
confessions of great
that are really something else so i'll
help you i just feel like this you know
i
mean
actually forward to saying that right
and she kind of just like
whacked my hands and i started flipping
out and stuff like that to the point
where i had to just like grab her and i
just would
lean forward and just press and it's
those police interviews
that help to tell this chilling story
tune in
to law and crime thanks jesse
coming up on law and crime daily 1.1
billion dollars a record settlement
for the hundreds of women who accuse a
usc gynecologist
of decades of sexual abuse plus the
accused killer of rapper nipsey hussell
is back in court
his legal arguments to reduce bail the
latest in the case
[Music]
next
attorneys for the man accused of
shooting and killing rapper nipsey
hussell
are asking for his 6.5 million dollar
bail
to be reduced the grammy-nominated
rapper was gunned down outside his los
angeles clothing store in april 2019.
police say eric holder walked up to him
and the two had a conversation about
hustle accusing holder
of snitching holder left but prosecutors
say he returned
shooting multiple rounds into hustle's
head and torso holder pled not guilty to
one count of murder
two counts of attempted murder and
weapons charges now
his attorneys say he's not a flight risk
and deserves a lower bond
how about the discovery man
well uh miss young and i are going to
meet and confer
with the investigating officer over
these items
and so i would think by the time we come
back on the 6th
we will have this settled and if not
i think we can either discuss what is
unsettled at that time or maybe
well if it's not so are you going to
file something in response
to her motion or yes
i'll do that okay
back with us as criminal defense
attorney bernard velona and co-host
terry austin
terry 6.5 million dollars is high but
that's better than the remand
we typically see in homicide cases right
yes it is but you know what brian i
think he should have been remanded to
jail this was a blatant
and bold killing of someone who was held
in extreme
high regard for the community and we
know that holder had a criminal
conviction
and that was for carrying a concealed
firearm
and the fact that he came back after an
argument
was shooting with two different guns and
two different hands
i think that that was just such a
heinous crime and frankly i think the
judge could have
easily remanded him so i'm hoping that
the bail stays at a very
high mark as you know strength of the
case is a factor that most courts
typically consider for bail
but is there a strong argument to have
bond reduced here
there's no reason to reduce the bond in
this case there has not been a change in
circumstances
he is awaiting trial so it's not like
any of the counts have been dismissed
so when it comes to california in
setting bail there's a computation
system that they use
it's one million off the top just if
you're facing life if you were to
convicted
be convicted of the sentence it's
another additional one million dollars
if you are
the shooter it's another 1 million
dollars if you have depending on your
prior record
so it is the best computation that you
use even though bail is only supposed to
be
to assure the return to court but also
you got to think about the public safety
yeah it is a of course a factor that
they put in and thank you for that
bernardo for showing us how that
calculus breaks down
i would agree with no change of
circumstances i don't see his bail
reducing unless something in his case
drastically changed but of course we'll
keep eyes on that case
thank you both when we come back how did
the alleged boulder store shooter obtain
the weapon that left
10 dead the new facts we are learning
about ahmad alisa
[Music]
welcome back new information in the
boulder store shooting case as we
learned the suspect passed a background
check
and legally purchased the alleged murder
weapon just six days before the deadly
rampage
a mona lisa is facing 10 counts of
murder and one count of attempted murder
prosecutors say they plan to file more
attempted murder charges
after 10 people were killed at the
king's superstore according to police
one officer fired at the suspect that
officer is now on paid administrative
leave
officials say law enforcement's response
saved additional lives
the officer an 11-year boulder police
department veteran
was not injured during the sentiment
the firearm used by the suspect in king
supers on march 22
is a semi-automatic ruger ar-556 pistol
it was legally purchased in a gun store
in arvada
colorado the defendant was also in
possession of a nine-millimeter handgun
but at this time we do not believe that
gun was used in this incident
the university of southern california
will pay out more than a billion dollars
to sexual assault victims of a former
campus gynecologist
george tyndall worked at the usc student
health clinic
from 1989 until 2016. that's when
allegations
he had been abusing students and taking
photos of their genitals without their
knowledge were made public in an la
times investigation
he has pled not guilty to 29 felony
charges and is awaiting trial
those settlements cover more than 700
plaintiffs is the largest sex abuse
payout in higher education history
i mean bernardo some of the details here
are astounding 1.1
billion dollar settlement over three
multiple settlements
scandal after scandal the university
officials calling it quote
the end of a painful and ugly chapter in
the history of the university
what are your thoughts on the settlement
so
of course the amount itself shows you
that there was culpability on the side
of the college
but i would tell you this the problem is
is that the college was well aware of
this
doctor's act since the 90s and it wasn't
until 2016
that they decided to take action against
this doctor and have him removed
so for the college to have failed those
ladies i think it's the right settlement
if not they should actually get more
because the reality is that they will
never forget what they went through
absolutely hundreds of victims as you
said earlier most
the most uh recent settlement because i
said there's more than one women will
see payouts from
a quarter million dollars to several
million terry how do you think
uh that the breakdown of these
settlements are working out in favor of
these women
well you know i think the large amounts
are worth it because
the amount of physical and emotional
distress that they went through
considering the fact these are students
you know i taught out at usc
after dr tyndale was there but during
the class action
and i heard students talking about the
ramifications of
what he did when he was at the school so
it might sound like an astronomical
figure
but i think it is as bernarda says
somewhat of an admission that the
university
failed to protect these students when
you have your child go off to school
the last thing you think about is the
fact that they might be abused by
someone at the school so i think it's
the right amount and i think it's a
great thing that the school is settling
because they're acknowledging
that they don't need to put these women
through a trial which would cause even
more emotional distress i mean
personally i find it disgusting
especially as an ncaa or i guess former
ncaa
college athlete myself when you go to
these schools you're supposed to be
welcomed into a family you're supposed
to be protected by
athletic trainers by coaches by by the
the
university as you go out there you try
to do your best
in a sport that you love to represent
that school it's it's maddening and
sickening
to hear that uh young women in college
had to go through this
i'm glad they got their civil court case
resolved and i look forward to seeing
how the criminal case has resolved as
well
thank you both and thank you for joining
us here at law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you